the michelin tire company 100 years ago  had a business problem  people weren't driving enough yet to  wear out their tires and thus they  didn't buy tires you know what they did  they started the michelin review  the reason there's three star michelins  my friends is because a tire company  needed people to drive and so they went  out to the countryside and started  reviewing the best restaurants and all  these things and made it up because they  probably wanted to say the best fog raw  was the furthest place out  then they took the books put it in  london and paris somebody would pick up  a book at the fancy you know place and  be like oh the best foie gras is in  burgundy honey we're going to burgundy  this weekend  they literally fixed their business  problem of using tires by getting people  to go far away by using media